who do you think is the best at
bowling Timmy does
Timmy you think it's Timmy
[Music]
too
good all right Timmy you ready he
[Music]
good hey hey okay have wait he wait on R
now
foot wrong
foot
fo I'll help you
out
good
nice you got a technique for
that done for 16 years I've never I've
never seen this uh a rail go up like
that done it for 16 years yeah what's
your name Alie what is it Alfie Alfie
I'm Mark Mark if you need me H Alie
thank you so much sir it's all time it's
Alie but a lot of times I can't say e
but I always say Alfie
Alfie thank you I'll take care you when
we're done okay thank you hey just watch
these little guys guys guys got to put
the name in first for you both oh you
got put your name in put your name in
got
it you get hey
hey no y ring
ring
[Applause]
right
she can go she can
[Music]
go
she got little
Clos
W
knock you
get
what
I done it you got to flick it down there
yeah
hold on Le hold
[Music]
on y up there make
sure now
you
[Music]
you got to try it try it
again
oh
ready
right where you watch take off your
jacket take off your
jacket come on
right come on
[Music]
R you enjoying
bowling you like
it
[Music]
here
all right
Timmy you want Timmy now you want to go
farther up you you can move farther
up
[Music]
oh you going to get a
strike
you're doing
[Music]
it
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
hey you got a
[Music]
strike Timmy you understand you can get
closer you can stand up
here you can stand here you're closer
that way yeah get
[Music]
closer
let
come
try
again
there you
go go
okay I don't I do it all
time
comes
out
wow heyo
[Music]
cute good
boy
you guys ready for
Christmas he's
ready
[Music]
okay yeah that one right
there hey Betty what what do you think
of stopping at Walmart and getting uh
like a Christmas tree and maybe some
gifts for you guys that's okay all right
let's do
it it's
okay come see
yes
starting to
walm
airport
and
St no help
you I got water work no programs will
help
you more
more turn left onto map's
[Music]
road yeah
Walmart
Ray
Ray come on over
here
[Music]
be for
now
[Music]
let's get a
cart Timmy you want to get a
cart get a
[Music]
cart
maybe get another
[Music]
C
where are your Christmas
trees H and thank
you what do you guys want for Christmas
Ray what do you
want you want stuff
animal
ready that okay I got
more you want a teddy
bear put in the
car
here's one
right here's
[Music]
one
no women's right there I want a man down
here
somewhere you going try to get a belt
for Ray again we tried before he never
wore it you wor a belt
Ray
yeah that way don't
ready Betty what do you want for
Christmas
you want some
[Music]
pajamas
Larry what do you want for Christmas
what do you want for Christmas
I what's that than pant your shirt you
well help yourself figure out what fits
you and grab it on
me
right there window right
there I can
yeah
Betty knows how to do
it Betty gets
it nice
one
great there in B
te ah
Kenneth get whatever you
need 20 what's that 20 Buck get him
on
Me Maybe we get suspenders for Ray
instead of a belt huh maybe we get
suspenders for Ray instead of a
belt he doesn't seem to like wearing
belts
ready you see belts
anywhere i' love to try getting you a
belt again I think you already got a
belt you just don't wear
it
West Virginia
nice this crowd won't keep it white for
long yeah no for you for me no no
no come
[Music]
on
Betty does Ray still have that belt I
got him last time we were at Walmart I
think he have I but sure he just won't
wear it right no he won't wear
Bel you'll wear a
belt Timmy's pants are Never Falling
Down
[Music]
Christmas
my
do you like
these you like
this which one you pick which
one that one you like it it looks like
it might be too big for her now okay
I'll gra a smaller one get you a smaller
one that's cute yeah I'll be right back
m
Timmy what do you want for Christmas
what what do you want for
[Applause]
Christmas
yeah that might fit
[Music]
better thank you Lauren
than you guys get whatever you
need get whatever you need right can
that's
great know I got nice one that's great I
got these
those beautiful
perfect right there come
on put right down here put right
down oh now I got
right
here yeah I know here's
belts what you we 30
32 ready you want you want another
belt see if they'll fit
back
it what you need
now looks pretty
good that
one all right all right there we go
there nice belt you got no excuse now
you had no excuse before cuz I got you
belt a year or two ago I know he don't
wear
belt we keep trying here
no I got bun of
B yeah L John more I that
me d right
here all
right you a going to get nothing
oh
304 right here man
right
feel how nice this
feels yeah feel how nice that
feels
you like it I don't what I say yeah I
can't find them what are you looking for
I'm T oh they're behind they're just a
couple rows behind you couple aisles
behind
you one size I'm I'm going to get this
for you for
Christmas
[Music]
right
there got ra not to keep warm that's for
Betty Betty for Betty
bab
in got there you go you guys are getting
with the
program BET's over
there we right here okay
watch you need
watch go get your
arm what do you want what's Timmy want
what's Timmy want you want a watch a
watch
watch I already going to get one he's
going to be telling me I'm late all the
time huh he's going to be telling me I'm
late all the time he already done
[Music]
that they saw my episode what that they
saw my interview who did these people
here oh I see
right oh
cool
some
jewelry never
know Timmy wants a
watch here
Timmy let me
see nice let's get it
I love
it very
cute yeah you want to where watch
Ray
Timmy you want a
watch take out a watch huh pick out a
watch there's there's men's watches over
here
get Timmy those are ladies these are
men's lry what do you what are you
thinking about H what are you thinking
about you're deep you're deep in
thought how you one in
Bowling you're regretting that pursuing
a career as a professional
bowler look at
that oh yeah
right I might have to get two of those I
might have to get two of those good
you guys are getting the hang of this
Walmart thing aren't
you oh oh that talk him about that what
do you what do you
want he want that Mark who does Ray Ray
wants
that okay there you go okay you got what
you want okay what'd you get he got a
monster truck a monster truck a g
that's that's that's what you want Ray
okay driving
now Betty last time we went to Walmart
lorine was looking at the lady's
underwear the bras and all that
stuff she's good she doesn't you got
it oh okay all
right
out of
luck just had to make sure yep nice
thought of
you what are
shoes what are you looking for the shoes
shoes
shoes might be on the other end of the
store think they said I think the I
think they said Christmas trees are over
here you want a Christmas tree huh can I
get you a Christmas
[Music]
tree
I
want see what they got huh let's see
what they
got
these are 7 foot 6
[Music]
foot
what' you
find a white Christmas tree beautiful I
love
it
some ornaments yeah get some
[Music]
ornaments you want to get some
ornaments I
got
where
[Music]
which one do you like
R you don't put that on the
tree okay another
one
ex
[Music]
some
of
[Music]
L right
there
what do you
get's going to Decor
got
mine I don't know who that baby
no that's Ray got
that want that you want
that right
there very
nicey you want it
Timmy you
Timmy
right who that who's
that
what want take it home with you right
you want to take it home with
you you put
any I like your
tree it's a nice tree I like ready
Cor
need W with paper
yeah
[Music]
oh you want to get
shoes we'll find
shoes
thank you so much for watch oh sure
sure
yeah back turn
light what's that for shoes
yeah
all want to take a
picture
pict take a
picture right a
picture put in right she want to take a
picture with me
a
Timmy Timmy look at look at Lauren timy
look at
[Music]
Lauren you got a good one it's hard to
get
Chistmas some guy insisted that we put
this towards it oh wow and I was like no
it's okay but people are Dona any money
at wmart I insist and I said no like
three times and I said all right that's
sweet
yeah so we got money towards yeah we'll
see if we I think we're spending more
this time than we did last
time they're getting the hang of it
[Music]
now yeah they're shy at first with them
yeah no bet bet is getting there she
figured this out get right there
ready come
on got some deer
[Music]
corn J
go come
[Music]
on Kenneth the last time we did this we
ran into you there at Walmart
remember the last time we I took the the
gang to Walmart we ran we ran into you
yeah we ran me
what's so like what are the odds well
there's only one store to go to here so
it's either Walmart or or you sit at
home and you stare at
[Music]
yourself
WR Paige told me you guys got a new TV
you guys got a new TV you
did
pretty
[Music]
man
here
baby
[Music]
what's your
name
me
really you like
those hey hey they look
comfortable
yeah here hold on relax relax
relax this goes with
it you like those you're 10 and a half
though that's not your size that's not
your size though Ray that's not your
[Music]
size R if you want if you want those
shoes I would get your size those are
too
bigas
[Music]
I'll take
these SA
he's he's buing size 10 and a half
shoes
he's buying sizes he's buying size 10
and a half shoes he's buying size 10 and
a half shoes yeah I I grabbed him a
smaller pair but he's he's buying two
sizes maybe put those put those back
and I mean they don't fit them they'll
be too big yeah they'll be too
[Music]
big
keep going after the air
fresh
hey right Cammy
you we
those here did he get a pair of shoes
yet put your hands right
there k your feet one
WI
I know
they have you
anywh you wear
that don't have to tie them huh you
don't have to tie them you just slip
them
on here is Bab I'm
done all right let's
go
there Ray oh there's
Ray
I got you got both
[Music]
yeah
my ear
you hurt my ear bro
so hard what's your
[Music]
name
they coming here
k
got get a get
G
sorry got keep it your seat okay sure
not get you
st
get whatever you want get whatever you
want
my
bab
dad
mom
5639 everybody go oh there she is she's
getting
candy
[Music]
get you
back yes
is
how are you how you doing tday sir great
how are
you hey
ma' h
got
did you like the
hanger you got the hanger did you like
the
hanger how are
[Music]
you do
Christmas at Mom May
no can I my picture with
[Music]
you Pi I don't take
picture at
the thank you
mommy you having a Merry Christmas thank
you I tell you everywhere we you guys
are stars
now you got to wait you got to
[Music]
wait stay right
there
you me ready can't put no more up
here all right there
you I think so okay did you get like
Electronics last we we got a microwave
but that was it was a microwave was the
most he can't
wait you spill your water ready you got
to pay for it first pay for it P for
it you didn't get that
concept r r
r put this check the
bag then we put these in bag why is that
oh for you yeah
yeah got my candy
up another buggy guys what's that
another buggy
yeah we might need another cart another
shopping cart cart another one no I mean
we got this one right
here Mar got that for
baby
car it's it's like a Shaw kind of thing
that's nice it's really
soft those are good yeah I like these
kind of I like those on
you got three I got one for your newly
Burger King so you can look nice your
new for your new girlfriend yeah I a got
a Girling with me oh you do yeah oh
you're a Playboy he I think got a girl
Ling with me
oh really yeah yeah you had a girl
hitting on you yesterday at Burger King
yeah she put the ladies love you huh the
ladies love you they
do they like that right there that what
they
like okay yeah wait
ready hey okay what great relax relax
wait a minute
already he's get
Nancy you want no no no warranty
[Music]
no come
on yeah
good boy he's getting it good
boy
got give me head on that ball
head
cute
right
hey man God bless yall sir thank you man
have a safe trip may go God bless thank
you man thank you so much God
bless come
on
go down
this
you
[Music]
what are you most excited
for got make sure Timmy's not
stealing
[Music]
where hey
I watch you all time on
YouTube yeah no
God bless you have a good night all
right
you want to put the tree on the table
huh and this is how you hit your
place
yeah
yeah what are you
doing
is this where Betty
sleeps Betty do you sleep on this huh
where do you sleep at
night oh you sleep over here I sleep
over here you can't even stretch out on
that
thing it's a tiny
sofa
I I us I us C the PO outside no in had
oh he's in the
[Music]
house youle yeah you sleep there I know
you
do that's raise
bed
Ser app this is warm over
here you burn
wood
[Music]
where that's watch wrong with me he just
took it
off you got your new shoes out I see
don't burn yourself hey Betty do we have
that Advil for uh for rais
knee
Betty
Betty oh oh she heard
me Tedy heard me she doesn't respond I'm
Str in my
hand you strength it's
cold
got
me
bro wait give one or two give him
two how are
you
cold sore no cold oh
cold are you sore from Bowling are you
sore yeah yeah California does get like
this you cold to outside I am here I'm
nice and warm by this thing your heater
is put yeah you got the right
seat they throw our heat no it does they
throw our heat way back there yeah it
heats up the whole
house whole
house I've never been here in Winter you
get here
you I've never been here in the
winter I've only I only visit you guys
in spring summer and fall yeah
yeah
on go dogs the dogs don't want to go out
you're not stupid
your from
[Music]
Walmart going get dog
now get dog B
leave
alone oh there's your
sweater who's that is that
BJ what's
that
you no I'm not I was just asking if
that's
BJ you put it down yeah I want to see
what it looks like on
her
these buttons
are
yeah
here how still without
us as far as I
know where shap they have an apartment
that's
[Music]
cute looks so pretty on you hey yeah you
got me
one you
should what's your take on there you go
now keep warm you don't have
to pretend that's
great
I her
option what are you showing
me good
on you can put your jacket
on
cute no I'm
[Music]
good
there's the extra bedroom they could
have back here oh really luren hereen
let me show you the bathroom oh I don't
want to no just just just take a look
just in case you need to use the
bathroom you're exaggerating it's not as
bad as
Afghanistan lovely it's pretty
horrible I'm not to it I
you hey
BJ hey
BJ bety you got no shower here you have
no shower I know you just take baths huh
you just take
baths nobody takes shower
[Music]
hereu
me
broke
I can't put broke
out yeah it
broke give me
yeah if you pull back and get
L pretty
sweater might
broke hey KY put some those in the back
do you want to put an ornament on fine
put put Tre up no more know where you
went all right
yeah
[Music]
ready
eight give one to R right yeah
put I one
I there you go you plug in the lights
put on the
tree
C you need an extension
c yeah put on the
tree that green you
get put one on there
right there you
go don't put it right there would want
that put it right
here H
me
P you electricity over here here take
in put it right there
exord here extension
cord put on have a here got in her hand
oh you got one yeah another
there where's the ex that I thought it
was another
P he got two plug in yeah hold the
extension C so don't you have one them
double plug
okay now plug it
in there we go
y
down put another one
up what you
doing
w
the
tree good job
Ray Ain my
P looks
good come
on beautiful tree yeah PR
drink no I got
star
baby you still got room for your raised
fruit
Lees I got any
watching
I
you should
get you want to one
up right get up hang that
upy I bet she walk up that
last that bowling took it out took it
out of her yesterday let's put it up on
the
tree go play go go on the
train yeah you got you put one on there
too
ready put it right here put it right
there
you hang it right
here
there you
go yeah right your
dream yeah your
[Applause]
dream
pry I know
Youk hey come back on here mark
he pretty tree beautiful tree
beautiful crazy up bur area on Santa
Claus yeah Santa
Claus he knows when every holiday comes
does yeah does he knows when Halloween
comes he knows when it's Thanksgiving he
knows when it's Christmas r ray is much
smarter
[Music]
than
he he there and get Pine
hross but I didn't
get back
here here Ray you get the
teddy a that's cute give him a
[Laughter]
hug we love the Ted